Netflix lets you revel in the good the
bad and the downright weird all from the
comfort of your living room it's a great
place to binge watch your favorite shows
but it's also a vast repository of
fantastic movies if you know how to find
them
wading through Netflix's recommendations
can be a daunting task so we rounded up
some of the best hidden gems on Netflix
for your viewing pleasure
turbo kid what happens when you roll
every post-apocalyptic trope into one
movie mix in absurd violence straight
from Quentin Tarantino's dreams and then
add superheroes probably something like
turbo kid a movie that plays like Mad
Max if the production crew could only
afford bicycles stay with us here
it's got wastelands a water war robots
Soylent Green jokes and an evil Michael
Ironside which everyone knows is the
best kind of Michael Ironside remember
this
[Music]
all right we're gonna do it the scan
away I'm gonna suck your brain dry
imagine that but with an eye patch and
less hair in the distant future of 1997
a loner kid survives one day at a time
in a wasteland scavenging junk to trade
for water to pass the time he reads The
Adventures of turbo rider a superhero
with a blaster cannon on his arm but
when he gets on the wrong side of the
local warlord he has to become the hero
himself to save his new friends don't
expect any deep insights into human
nature with turbo kid just enjoy it for
what it is a goofy romp through the
imagination of someone who probably grew
up wearing out the scan lines on their
Robocop laserdisc
I don't feel at home in this world
anymore Colin Frodo all you want but
Elijah Wood is working hard to reinvent
his image as an actor and we can totally
respect that
from his mannequin obsessed killer in
2012 maniacs to his dirty cop con man in
2016's the trust Wood is clearly capable
of branching out in I don't feel at home
in this world anymore
Wood plays a geeky loner who teams up
with a woman in his neighborhood to find
the people who robbed her house don't
let the title bog you down it's a black
comedy in the vein of the Coen brothers
Fargo and Burn After Reading a subtle
escalating thriller about two everyday
people rust over their heads into a
world of crime where anything can and
does go wrong I don't feel at home in
this world anymore is moody occasionally
hilarious and surprisingly pointed I'm
not letting you shoot anyone
anyone anyone else maki if you've never
watched much Bollywood it may be hard to
tell if Maki is making fun of those
films or comfortably nestled at the
heart of it all
the absurdity feels intentionally
cranked to 11 but then again there's
also a distinct possibility that a song
and dance number followed by a Rakhi
training montage for a reincarnated fly
is completely normal
either way it's totally worth your time
to watch here's the premise and it's a
doozy a fly born from the soul of a dead
man goes on a revenge rampage against
the guy who killed him it's John wick
crossed with a bug's life crossed with
lala land
maybe there's a trippy ant-man vibe to
the visuals and explosive action
sequences all tied into a deathmatch
between a manned and wealth a housefly
as far as hidden gems go this one's like
stumbling across a dead unicorn in the
woods it's majestic and you just don't
know what the hell to do with it Harlock
space pirate from the outset you can
look at Harlock space pirate and expect
a rocket fueled amount of fun after all
a movie with the gumption to call itself
exactly what it is in the title isn't
about to bore you with over long tedious
insights into the internal struggles of
being a space pirate no you're getting
spaceships laser bombs robot suits and
in case you missed it the first time
space pirates based on a Japanese manga
Harlock space pirate was well received
on its release in 2013 and even won best
international animated feature at the 3d
Creative Arts Awards but the cg
spectacle didn't come anywhere close to
making back its production budget and
ultimately fail to find much of an
audience does that mean you should steer
clear of Harlock not even close
if the geek pleasure centers of your
brain light up at the thought of a
well-made beautifully animated sci-fi
adventure you'll definitely get a kick
out of Harlock space pirate the V ver
Mel Gibson had a rough couple years in
the mid aughts and although he's now got
another oscar-winning film under his
belt his return to hollywood didn't come
without a few false starts in 2011 he
starred in Jodie Foster's film the
beaver as Walter black the CEO of a toy
company who has a nervous breakdown
loose
family and tries to hang himself from a
hotel shower curtain on the edge of
death black snaps completely and allows
his life to be taken over by a beaver
puppet only one really really it's
technically a comedy but dark doesn't
come close to describing the humor this
is blacker than a coal mine after a
cave-in an intimate portrait of
depression and mental illness that flows
so seamlessly from Gibsons acting that
you can't help but believe he's
channeling his own personal experiences
with incredible supporting performances
from Jodie Foster Anton Yelchin and
Jennifer Lawrence the beaver is
definitely a hidden gem worth watching
if only once
although afterward you may need to watch
something a little more lighthearted
like the human centipede thanks for
watching
flick the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]